the - it from my MLB network as well as
Fox Sports and the NHL Network as well
John Palmer OC good to see you bud
Richard is great to be back in of course
Brady and Jeter a couple men as you do
with Michigan ties Derek was on campus
briefly Mountie for a cup of coffee
caress was he there in Michigan he so he
never played for the maize and blue of
course because I signed but he attended
classes there and trained there for a
semester now was that as leverage
against the Yankee's we met in a way for
leverage I think he was there Simon
there and I may not have the exact
particulars of the story right ribs I
believe when he was there it was during
the the lockout following the baseball
strike and I thank you for I was
actually there when Alan Trammell was
was on campus as an assistant coach
because he didn't have anything to do
with with baseball being out so I think
actually Jeter and Trammell or on campus
at U of M at the same so the 94 season
goes kaput right
just round then yes when Jeter is is
yeah he's kicking he's kicking the tires
well he won't do any thought in Mellon
he's not going back to school that's for
sure now that he's down there in Miami
let's I guess start with that right now
how do you see Miami's season playing
out again I know that we don't usually
talk about teams that are 15 games under
500 but when you've got a somebody like
Jeter in the front office and all the
news that had been in the spotlight cast
on him prior to the season his real
sports conversation with Brian Gumbel
was fascinating yes Don Mattingly
sitting there in the dugout what do you
think about what the Marlins have been
able to put on the field here well rich
they're still in the very early stages
of this rebuild and they're in a very
competitive division the Mets have
regressed a bit obviously since the
start of the season but the Nationals
still going for it and the Phillies in
the Braves with the Braves being the
first place their rebuilds are ahead of
schedule so I think it really
underscores the challenge in front of
them but I give Derek credit for
articulating the process that they want
to have and staying with it and I think
they'll probably make a couple more
moves at the deadline this year maybe
Justin bour could be traded out Miguel
Rojas Derek Dietrich they have some some
pieces there to move JT Realmuto is
probably the one that has the most
valuable they will they want to keep
them internally but it just it's a
challenging division right now rich
because of the quality of
the Braves and the Phillies joining now
the Nationals tough division I believe
for the next several about three weeks
to go until the all-star break we're
gonna be in DC our show will be in DC
the day of the Home Run Derby all-star
Tuesday and then Wednesday as well what
do you think the story of the baseball
season is right now John I think rich to
me we are seeing the Red Sox and Yankees
back to their customary position as the
big two in baseball now certainly the
Astros are there the defending World
Series champions their record is
basically the same as as the two teams
in the American League East but it's
taken me back now 15 years basically to
the to the that time right before the
Red Sox broke the curse that we're
seeing the Red Sox and Yankees
sustainably being arguably the two best
teams in the game again they've both
sort of been on a stage and away from
the stage based on their mini rebuilds
and the Red Sox have had some boom and
bust cycles where they've been a World
Series team and then gone back down to
the bottom of the division but I think
now we're seeing those two teams back
along with the Astros as being the
classes of the American League and and I
think too we've got a number of great
young stars which we talk a lot about
where we're at as a sport and Mike Trout
gets better and better by the year and
and where maybe those next baseball
icons are coming to me they're here
they're they've already arrived in trout
and Nolan Arenado Bryce Harper's numbers
are down a little bit this year but
still I think the superstar quality is
there for him and this next generation
of players we're seeing coming
Ozzie alibies and Glaber Torres but with
the Yankees it's just it's a really
exciting time to be a fan of the
national past oh yeah and you you have
the defending American League MVP and
Jose Altuve just lighting it up again
for the Houston Astros and well let's
sit under out a little bit here our show
is every single day broadcast on angels
radio here in Southern California que la
a a.m. 8:30 and trout is as great as
ever as great as ever and pool holes in
his dotage on occasion can put the ball
out of the yard
Oh tani what a unfortunate turn of
events has been for him with his injury
but where where do things stand in year
1 million of the Mike Scioscia era for
the Angels John it's a great question
rich because they're at a spot now where
the
as we speak today have now tied them for
third in the American League West they
have been a little listless since Oh
townies been out I think as a team
trout again brilliant as ever but
collectively they've had some injuries
now with the pitching staff as well
Garrett Richards being on the DL is that
Cozart a really key member their
everyday lineup he has been out as well
so the a is with a lot of youth and
momentum now have caught them and and
there's still seven games back of the
Mariners for the second wild-card so the
chances of trout getting back to the
playoffs now he's only been there once
in his entire career the chances for
trout getting back to the playoffs now
are getting slimmer by the day and I
really think rich for us those of us to
follow baseball every day we see we see
how brilliant trout is but I think for
him to take that next step as being not
just the best player in baseball but
American sports icon he's got to get
back to the playoffs he has played three
postseason games in his career and he
has won none of them and I think that
until he gets to that level again and
has success that's to me we talked about
Jeter a moment ago the magic of Jeter
yes a great players going to the Hall of
Fame but part of his legend was he
played for the Yankees and he won all
World Series rings right at the
beginning of his career he was there
every time we ever turn in our TVs in in
October he was there and trout hasn't
been there and I think for for this
sport to have that iconic player in
trout he has to get there at some point
time on a consistent basis of certain
metrics best numbers in the history of
the game
yes through 1,000 right here play games
for Mike chomp best ever remembered
you're right I don't even need to go
down the list of people who have
practice but he's the many is the mantle
how is it not translated into October
visits and wins then it's a great point
and it really I think it's been
inconsistent pitching for the angels for
a long period of time they've had some
near misses they've had some quality
teams that have just fallen just short
including last year where they were
really competitive to the very end but
it's it is a it's been a difficult story
thing for baseball to wrap its mind
around how a player this great can be on
a team that doesn't make the plas and
that's where I think it's fundamentally
different we talked about the comparison
between LeBron and Mike Trout LeBron is
in the playoffs every year he's
basically in the finals least in recent
times
every single year and and the NBA is a
sport where one player can exert that
level of of influence on the entire team
and dominate a game you know if you're
watching LeBron play you're probably
gonna see him score 25 a night no matter
what Mike Trout he may go over three on
that particular night and one player in
baseball cannot will his team to the
playoffs in the way that I think LeBron
James can well my kids know him I mean
my kids dig him they know who Mike Trout
is and hopefully but they live here in
Southern California the Honda inside a
rapport with the JP Morosi John Palmer
OC of MLB Network and Fox Sports joining
me here on the show and yet again you
mentioned they're there within an area
code right for sure along with the A's
of that second wild card spot where all
you need to do is go on the road and
seemingly I think what you're gonna have
to do beat a 100 win team named the Red
Sox for the Yankees in that amazing I
mean is is there some conversation to be
had in Major League Baseball about
making it more than just a one game and
out situation for team to win a hundred
games and then have an opportunity to
maybe just get beat on any given night
as it can happen in baseball yes okay it
is a topic we saw it actually a couple
years ago where the best three records
in the game all came from the NL Central
we had that wild-card game between the
Pirates and the Cubs right and the
Pirates I believe were a 99 win team out
with one loss at home and actually we
talked about the dominance of the
American League one quick point on that
the Red Sox Yankees and Astros if they
all finished with a 650 or better
winning percentage which they all very
reasonably could do yes there'll be the
first time we have three teams with a
650 or better winning percentage in the
major leagues since 1942 so we're seeing
this really top heavy structure of the
game right now well Mike that's an old
gen stat hit old gen stat right there
that's an old gen staff
we had our 1st 1942 reference 19 full I
mean that's an old gen stat right there
wow that's yeah as my winding answer
came back around to the actual question
which was the playoff structure could we
see it change yeah and and the answer
that is once baseball gets to 32 teams
which I believe they will the
Commissioner has said he wants to do
that you look at the structure of the
game at that point in time and Jason
Starks written about this recently and I
think very eloquently and insightfully
about where the were things stand once
baseball gets to 32 teams then you have
eight divisions of four teams probably a
universal D H across baseball and the
first round becomes the best of three
where you're able to welcome in more
playoff teams John Palmer OC here is
part of the insider report which is
brought to you by our friends at Honda
and the fourth of July sales event it's
the best place to get a great deal on a
new Honda like the Accord Civic or fit
so head to your local Honda dealer today
for a sizzling deal on a Honda you will
love when we come back I want to hit a
little bit more on some of the young
players that we haven't heard much about
talk a little bit about the looming
trade deadline and who might be coming
to Los Angeles great third base or
shortstop most likely shortstop from the
Baltimore Orioles I think you know what
I'm blowing out of there with Manny
Machado and a little bit more
conversation on on one of those young
players that you've already mentioned
that's with John Palmer OC when we come
back here in the Rich Eisen show John
Palmer OC of Fox Sports and MLB Network
here he is Aussie alby's the youngest
Braves player at 21 years old to hit a
walk-off home run since Andruw Jones did
it at 20 years old in 1997 is that
considered an old gen stat when it's
over 20 years old involving somebody who
was 20 at the time you're not born yet
when you beat the stat I think that
counts how good is this kid man he's
special rich in this at one point in
time the Braves had the three youngest
players in the National League all on
their active roster
alby's Ronald Acuna jr. and Mike Soroka
from Calgary Alberta Canada the
right-handed pitcher and alby's if you
look at his projections right now
probably gonna hit more than 30 homers
this season I believe he'll be the first
21 year old middle infielder to do that
since Alex Rodriguez he is that good and
middle and fielder premium ability I
think the Braves rich I love the story
about Atlanta getting good again because
there are a lot of people who grew up in
the 90s watching TBS all around the
country not just in the southeast they
were I know Curtis Granderson for
example grew up in Chicago Braves fan
because this was the team that everybody
watching the 90s so it's Marshall Faulk
growing up in New Orleans is a Braves
fan because all he all he could watch in
the Bayou were Braves games on the super
system exactly so it the Braves are we
talking about teams with national
profile in baseball yeah the Braves have
it maybe not quite in the way that the
Yankees are Dodgers do but in their own
unique way and so to me it is great for
baseball that the Braves are in first
place and potentially go back to the
plan they've got the largest lead of any
team in the national leagues right now
at 13 games over three and a half better
than Philadelphia's Milwaukee leads the
Cubs who were in Dodger Stadium tonight
at 2 and a half and the Dodgers who beat
the Cubs last night I mean they're seven
over right now and and and Kershaw is
not even die single think rice you're
essential he's pitched basically nine
innings since the first of May and the
Dodgers have the best record in baseball
by a wide margin since May 17th on the
morning of May 17th they were 10 games
under as you mentioned now seven over I
mean they have had a transformation I
think the getting healthy has helped
them I think some great stories like max
Muncie what he has done for them has
been extraordinary Bellinger I the way
max Muncie sounds like somebody straight
out of the out of the natural are you
right
right max was max Muncie the next Mercy
West mercy was the Robert Duvall that's
right sports writer cartoonist as well
that he was drawing he's drawing
okay max Muncie what a name and that
Dodgers lead the National League in home
runs right now Matt Kendell Matt Kemp is
going to be an all-star there was a
thought that he might have been released
at the end of spring training that
basically that trade was a financial
transaction only it was
to help accommodate the luxury tax and
he is going to be an all-star Richie is
playing this is basically he has wound
back the clock ten years and I love that
about baseball house every now and then
we will have a season that defies any
reasonable expectation and right now
Matt Kemp is doing that for Los Angeles
amazing it's amazing how that's
happening right now
JP Morosi here on the Rich Eisen show so
you've got you've got that going on in
the National League West Houston is as
good as it gets man we had we at AJ
Hinch on last he's a great manager I
love I just love talking to him he is a
great conversationalist great leader man
and I made the mistake of asking hey
would you be up for getting rid of the
shift and his answer absolutely not and
I'm like but as a fan I don't want to
see Bryce Harper punt I don't want to
see hey here's half the field Bryce go
there yeah I want to see him swinging
and and and and he's like well Bryce is
good enough to hit it out of the park to
the to left field cuz to me it's just it
I don't know these guys are so good at
figuring out exactly where to place play
right now right well I don't know how
they do you know the the scouting
process and how shifts are actually put
into place because to me I think as you
pointed out I think you might not be on
the air but when we were you were
sitting down there the strikeout the the
the three true outrage walks strikeouts
home runs that's been happening in
baseball right now something we've got
to get some more sprinkle in some other
stuff and I think the shift is the
problem exactly to your point rich I
think it makes hitters all the more
focused on trying to elevate the ball if
they feel like anything on the ground is
gonna be out and that the shift is
taking away their hits they're gonna
become increasingly focused on elevating
the ball that's what we're seeing right
now I think you know Tom Verducci has
done some great work on this and
analyzing it and what might happen two
possibilities either you have a mandate
of having two fielders on either side of
second base for every pitch yes or and
tom has made a great point about this
potentially forcing all infielders to
have at least one foot on the dirt when
the pitch is delivered that would at
least take away some of that short right
field
where you've got the the rover playing
out out there right between the it's
crazy the dirt in the wall and it's a
ground ball off of the bat of a big
lefty power hitter and he's able to
throw him out of first base from short
right-field I think I think rich in
general we we as a we as people that who
love baseball have to look at this and
say are we really capturing the essence
of the game is this really the way the
game is meant to be played and if if the
game is evolving in a way that's counter
to the game's essence I think you have
to take a really hard look at changing
the rules to make sure that the spirit
of the game is preserved and is engaging
especially young fans as much as it can
well we're scheduled to have the
Commissioner on in our DC shows so we'll
ask the Commissioner that then when
we're at the at the all-star game how
hot will the Manny Machado marketly do
you think with a trade deadline I think
10 days hence right at point in time he
is the biggest prize rich I think on the
on the trade market this the summer
Manny Machado because of the multi
positional value he's got we could play
some short he could play some third
whether it's the Dodgers to play
shortstop whether it's the Phillies of
the Braves those younger up-and-coming
teams I could see him being a great fit
there
the Yankees and Red Sox like me now
before they've got enough rich they got
another I think I think he's going to
the National League I I'd love him in
Milwaukee I think about walk he is a
sneaky bold team right now because they
they could have gone for it last year
that a young GM david stern's was very
good and turns out Jose Quintana goes to
the rivals in Chicago and really the
Cubs never looked back last year during
the regular season I think now the
Brewers whether it's a starting pitcher
or maybe one more impact infield bat
like Machado I would love Machado going
to a team like the Brewers are really
enliven that national central well I
mean if you're trying to peg one player
who might tip the balance in a
postseason in the same way that you just
mentioned with Jose Quintana for for me
having you know following the Yankees as
I do
Gerrit Cole could be that guy that that
the Yankees had him targeted yes and
couldn't get him where's the swing at
him right and then he goes to Houston
and he has been phenomenal part of a
rotation that is
off the charts leading teams like the
Yankees out or the Red Sox looking for
pitching to when it all comes down to
this everybody could use everybody but
so what's the pitching market gonna look
like in July that doesn't seem to be a
Verlander out there this year that
somebody could just say all right we'll
take his absurd salary all right and is
there anybody else well it's interesting
which I would say Cole Hamels maybe fits
that description a little bit of
Verlander type someone who's achieved so
much earlier in his career is on a
larger contract and I know when we
talked last year the deadline we were
sitting and sitting right here having
this conversation Verlander was a big
topic of discussion back then Huston was
so uh I mean I think the Dallas Keuchel
went on record saying our front office
is not trying very hard cuz I didn't
pull the trigger at the deadline but did
obviously when it was in the waiver
period it was such the last second yeah
Verlander's told me the story that
basically it was 11:59 and 57 seconds
the timestamp of the email that
confirmed that the trade happened it was
it was literally seconds and of course
that transaction rich changed the the
whole course of the playoffs and what
happened not far from here at Dodger
Stadium in Game seven and of course
Verlander pitch came six but it was
amazing the way that Verlander swung
that entire postseason picture on that
one decision with seconds left before
the deadline and I think too we talked
so much about the way that the great
pitchers like Verlander can reinvent
themselves and I think we're seeing it
happen a little bit with Felix Hernandez
in Seattle he's out of good run here
recently
Felix has never pitched in the playoffs
rich a great player a scion winner has
never been in the playoffs and with the
Buffalo Bills finally making the
playoffs last year the Mariners another
great national team and you think about
Griffey and the Heritage they're right
they have not made the playoffs since oh
one that's the longest postseason
droughts in all of major pro sports they
are in position to end that drought
right now and I think for them talk
about the pitching market whether it's a
Jay Happ from Toronto maybe going to
Seattle or one of the more controllable
pieces one name to remember right now
Blake Snell denier no hitter last night
Blake Snell in a what's a pretty thin
pitching market right now unless Jacob
degrom is moved by the Mets Blake Snell
as a name to watch very carefully he has
really emerged a young lefty there were
Tampa Bay 10 Bay is always in that sort
of
building mode or at least looking for
ways to optimize the value of their
players Blake's now right now is a big
time so to bring it all full circle with
us talking in the first segment with you
about Mike trout's only played in three
postseason games and what a shame that
is Felix Hernandez is like holding my
cerveza right never zero I mean and so
last thing for you is is Bumgarner and
that's a pure fantasy I mean cuz
obviously the Giants have a shot here
just three out of the wildcard four and
a half out of first place but you know
definitely a Yankee fan fantasy that
somehow madbum winds up with the Yankees
and he adds them to this list of so many
generationally talented young players
for October it's a great point and I
think that's a team to watch really
carefully rich in the coming weeks
because there are there's some optimism
that maybe once Samara and Cueto get
back and rolling that they could get
back into this nationally west race but
I look at the way the Dodgers are
playing right now and say to myself I
don't see the Giants passing them and if
the Giants are not gonna pass them and
they've already invested so much money
in this year's team they've got an old
team and when you've got an old team
that's not in first place you'd better
take a long look at ways to get younger
and reposition yourself for the future
and if that's the case Bumgarner being
available I would say check back in a
couple weeks at the all-star break when
you're there in DC I think the Bumgarner
trade possibility if the Giants have a
rough couple weeks could be very present
and very real at that point alright last
thing for you I was told Don Bowie my
coronary producer got my ear and say you
John Palmer knows who I know lives in
Ann Arbor Michigan you have some
interesting information on how Harbaugh
called up see Webb and said let's get
together let's get let's triangle I
don't have the inside story on that
exactly how the conversation went but
III would say this as a michigan
resident and and lifelong michigan fan
i'm excited i think chris weber belongs
as part of the family
although michigan has never quite been
so great in football as it was when you
were there as the honorary game captain
so i think rich come home back to NR but
we need you back because the last time
you showed up the maize and blue were
one spot away yes from that big 10 title
game so I think we need you back on K
well my my my timing was perfect because
I was the honorary captain against
Central Florida in the year that they
had no
no losses against yes ucf good to see
you sir thanks for coming on great John
Merrow see on Twitter no H at Jo and mor
OSI on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience